peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour amis agents de l'edf vous qui
nous apporter la lumière alors vous les
releveurs de compteurs vous les coupures
d'électricité
sachez que vous étaient plus exposés aux
morsures de chiens depuis quatre ans
nous avons eu très accidents du travail
lié aux morsures de chiens nous avons
décidé deux axes en interne et en
externe en interne auprès de nos agents
nous avons fait venir le commandant tome
de l'école des maîtres chiens de
gendarmerie de gramat et en externe nous
avons envoyé une enveloppe hommes à tous
nos clients sur laquelle figure le
graphisme d'un chien graphismes assez
humoristique pour sensibiliser notre
clientèle ou fait que nous sommes à
leurs services mais qu'il doit faire
attention à leur chien puisque quand
même nos agents sont régulièrement
agressés comme les agents des ptt
d'ailleurs évité de regarder un chien
fixement dans les yeux il pourrait
prendre ça pour de la provocation bien
qu'on vous dise de ne jamais quitter un
chien des yeux pour éviter vous ferment
souvent et ça c'est les maîtres qui font
cette erreur il place la niche près du
compteur vous allez relever alors la
première fois que vous passez demander
gentiment omettre de bien vouloir
changer la ligue iota de façon que vous
ne soyez pas dans la ligne critique du
chien cette ligne fameuse ligne où il a
décidé de mordre
lorsque nous arrivons en campagne chez
des clients nous avons l'habitude de
nous faire entendre enfin personne de
voiture et lorsque je suis arrivé chez
cette clientèle à elle est sortie et en
même temps sa meute de chiens parmi ces
chiens a mordu à la cuisse ne m'a pas
cru et devant les faits étaient obligés
de
comme on dit de baisser le pantalon pour
lui faire voir vous avez été mordue mais
je continue cependant à relever son
compteur tous les six mois et malgré
cela nous avons de très bons alors c'est
la mienne ça va mieux je vais sur ceux
du passé c'est du passé
rivard de terre mais oui je sais le
docteur de pantomime piqûres et je pense
que vous avez dû être convoquées
également parlé des f
je m'appelle ouvertement d'oulchy
retraités des industries électriques et
gazières depuis trois ans et j'ai mon
palmarès cette morsure de chien
heureusement sans gravité
une morsure que j'ai préféré parce que
je me présente chez
donc chez un client pour le un compteur
à l'époque ont porté des pantalons
diffuser la chaîne moment derrière le
jeunot l'hôtesse de la maison de
a voulu me soigner a m'a demandé de
relever mon pantalon
mais j'ai pas pu j'ai été obligé de le
baisser donc puis deux minutes après la
morsure de chien en espagne c'est plus
je veux dire que j'avais trouvé une
solution idéale c'était de surprendre de
chiens et de commencer par le monde soi
même comme ça ils savaient plus quoi
faire
mais ça c'est celle a noté maurice tic
qu'on allait df souvent christian garcia
mon maître ancien releveur j'étais mordu
pendant mon activité
trois fois par la première fois c'est un
griffon la deuxième fois un berger
allemand et la troisième fois c'était un
petit bandit pagnol breton bien
maintenant messieurs les agents je vais
vous demander lorsque vous serez devant
une propriété où il ya un chien de bien
observer ce chien de façon à pouvoir
déterminer si vous avez affaire à un
chien dominant ou un chien dominé si
vous avez à faire un chien dominant vous
le verrez bien campée sur ses pattes
le buste haut les oreilles dressées le
regard fixe devant lui et le fouet ce
que nous appelons vulgairement la queue
alors et à l'horizontale voire même
verticale et un 13 ans roulait
apparemment c'est court et en porter
leurs fruits puisque les accidents sont
dus aux morsures de chiens sont quand
même un être resté onze sur le centre de
périgueux
je crois savoir que le chien dominé les
oreilles baissées et la queue basse
alors que le chien dominant tout à fait
le contraire que droite mais je vous dis
c'est pas toujours évidemment lorsque
surtout lorsqu'il sort précipitamment de
la maison je rejoins ce que dit monsieur
de l'âge sur les chaînes dominants et
les chaînes dominer moi je
je pense cette chose là mais je ne le
savais pas ce nom ce qui est déterminant
c'est sur cette phraséologie si vous les
voyez les chaînes les plus dangereux
c'est ce qu'ils ne font pas de bruit qui
rasait les murs qui passait par derrière
et puis qui vous agresser chez une
cousine du bruit ma foi sont moins
dangereux les affectionne
particulièrement le montagne des
pyrénées est également le griffon qui
m'a agressé sournoisement dans le dos
mais il sans aucune conséquence sans
aucune blessure
le meuble ma retraite par une activité
folklorique 1 et notamment je suis
joueur de vielle à roue et je débute
l'accordéon diatonique à ce qui permet
de peut-être me familiariser avec les
chiens de l'est de les amadouer un petit
peu au moins je veux pas et conseillé à
mes camarades l'amener au moins une
cassette
sinon pas s'ils ne savent pas jouer et
de vielles à roue de cornemuse et
d'amener des à musique folklorique est
est aussi jamais c'est une thérapeutique
valable contre les morsures de chiens
messieurs les agents d'edf au tamis mon
propos voici ce que vous encourez si
vous ne respectez pas les consignes
sécurité pour avoir voulu aller trop
vite en besogne
je me suis fait passer et tout ça en
voulant même respecter les mesures de
sécurité alors faites très attention
afin que ce genre de mésaventure nous
arrive pas nos agents sens à votre
service dites le à votre chien
merci à ben c'est pas mal oui mais je
vais le dire à mon chien s'est entendu
voilà
[Musique]